Doctor, we've talked about inflammation
being a root cause of actually many
different things. Where does that start
from? What what causes inflammation that
in turn leads to many other conditions?
Life causes inflammation. I mean, it
does, right? The second law of
thermodynamics is everything dissolves
and decays. That's a law of physics. The
second law of thermodynamics. Mountains
turn to dust, iron turns to rust.
Everything decays all of the time. The
same thing is happening in the human
body. Interestingly enough, the human
body has uh a police department which is
the immune system. It also has a fire
department which nobody talks about
which is the body's ability to put out
the fires of inflammation which are a
normal part of life. So for instance,
you walk down the street and you breathe
in carbon monoxide from an automobile
exhaust. Carbon monoxide goes into the
body and creates the formation of
something in the body called a free
radical. A free radical is an oxygen
atom that's lost an electron. And an
oxygen atom that's lost an electron will
stick to anything. It's like metabolic
Velcro. Now, when enough oxygen atoms
stick to something, whatever it got
stuck to becomes
oxidized. And when something becomes
oxidized, it ultimately becomes
destroyed. Right? That's why iron turns
to rust. So oxidative damage inside the
body is the main causitive factor of
inflammation. Now, if the body is
properly neutrified, it can handle
normal oxidative stress that's present
just from walking down the street. But
if the body is not neutrified, you know,
it's like the hook and ladder truck
showing up at the house that's on fired
and it hooks the hose up to the hydrant,
but there's no water in the hydrant.
Well, if there's no water, you can't put
the fire out. If the body is out of
essential nutrients, the fire department
can't work. So the normal inflammation
that's just a part of day-to-day life
gets the upper hand. So there's two
things that are necessary in in this
domain in this regard, right? We have to
support the fire department of the body
and we do that with 90 essential
nutrients especially selenium. Selenium
is extremely important and the whole
concept of nutrative antioxidants,
right? This is the the domain of
antioxidants. Antioxidants are like the
water that the fire department uses.
This is why consuming food uh and
beverages or nutritional supplements
that are high in antioxidants is
extremely important for you know health
of the human body. But in addition to
giving the fire department of the body
the raw materials that it needs to work,
we also would be would be prudent for us
to take steps to avoid being exposed to
things in the environment that cause
inflammation and create free radicals.
You know what the biggest cause of free
radicals from our point of view is?
Fried food
and oil in a bottle. What's that? That's
right. Everybody's favorite, olive oil.
Oil in a bottle, salad dressing
eventually will oxidize. And when you
consume anything that's become oxidized,
you have free radicals in your body. So
eating salad is like loading up on free
radicals. And if you fry a food, forget
it. It's interesting. If you look at a
map of life expectancy in the United
States, right? Life expectancy county by
county in the entire United States. The
part of the country that has the lowest
life expectancy, and it's dramatically
so, is the old South, the old
Confederate South. Why is that? They've
got the same education, they've got the
same water, they've got the same sewer,
they've got the same drugs, they've got
the same insurance, they've got the same
hospitals. Everything is the same except
one thing. In the South, fried food is a
religion. They eat more fried food in
the south than anywhere else in the
United States with the possible
exception of Native American
reservations around the country, which
also extremely high in fried food. When
you go overboard with fried food, you
load your body up on free radicals. Your
body does not have the raw materials to
put those fires out, and so your body
decays faster. This is why people that
live in the Confederate South have the
lowest life expecties of anybody in the
US. And nobody is talking about it
except us.